So today we've talked about common sense reasoning. Broadly, common sense
reasoning gives us a formal structure to interpret the world around us.
Having that formal structure let's us build agents that can then do the same.
We started off with primitive actions, which like primitives in programming,
are the simplest things we can interpret out the world. Then we looked at
composing those primitive actions into bigger actions. For a hierarchical,
abstract view of the world. We then looked at how those primitives can
cause state changes, which let us predict the effect or cause of certain events.
Next time, we're going to compose these simple frames into much longer stories,
called scripts. Scripts help us make sense of complex repeated events with
relative ease, and generate expectations about the world around us.